Some people like to watch bonus content -
- You are the bonus content…
- Check it out…
You are the living bonus content.
- There you go.
It says that on my business card.
Welcome to Monarch, General.
This is gonna give me nightmares.
[MONSTER ROARS]
One of the things
that really appealed to us was that,
before now,
you’re always inside Monarch.
- Everybody gets a parka.
Yeah, exactly, everybody
has the branded Monarch gear.
And what we wanted to do
was to turn the perspective around
and have a group of characters
who were on the outside looking in.
- What’s Monarch?
- I don’t know.
- Monarch is just as unknown and monstrous…
- And scary!
Are these guys
good guys or bad guys?
We don’t know.
- The whole city was coming down...
These guys were taking pictures.
- We want to pull back the curtain on that
and show you how it became
the organization that you now see.
- We have to bring Monarch
out of the shadows.
- Going into the Monsterverse,
we had to figure out
what’s the best version of the show.
The first question I asked was,
does it have to be about the monsters?
I think it should be about
this messed up family.
And it’s that journey that takes you
into the world of the monsters.
[YELLS]
[MONSTERS ROARING]
- In this new world,
monsters are like hurricanes,
it’s a reality of the world you live in.
Let’s tell a story about people
with that as the backdrop.
A lot of the Monsterverse
fans are going to come for
the Titans, they’re going to come for
cities being knocked down,
but the show will be about people
getting back up again.
- The only way out is through.
- Our internal shorthand has been like,
it’s not a 9/11 show, it’s a 9/12 show.
It’s about the first time you had to take
your shoes off at the airport.
- This changes everything.
- It’s a story about the Titans,
but also about a group of people
who are dealing with their own monsters.
Everybody’s dealing with
their own monsters.
- It is your family business.
- It’s the family curse.
- Over the season, we hop
from era to era,
and fill in more of the blanks,
but not all of them.
So we still have questions to answer,
and we’re asking even more
that push everything forward.
- If you come with me,
you’ll know everything,
I promise you.
- Oh my God, go go go!